I'm an atheist but I align more closely
with a Christian conservative worldview
and so
I pretty much support Christian
conservatism that horror that whole
moral compass and so that's what I stand
for yeah that I mean that's that's
really sad in that it is so mixed up and
jumbled I'm an atheist but the morality
of Christian conservatism strikes me as
correct therefore
I am going to support candidates who
actually think that I as an atheist
should have a subservient or secondary
status to them because they believe that
we should have a country that is overtly
Christian in terms of civil government
it's all really really whacked